after a PC launch plagued with extensive
performance issues batman arkham knight
rose up from the Lazarus Pit and
relaunched on Steam last Wednesday sadly
it wasn't a very successful resurgence
for the world's greatest detective with
publisher Warner Brothers now offering
unconditional refunds for PC players I'm
Lucy and together let's solve the
mystery a Batman's poor pc port but
those opting to try out the re-released
version of Arkham Knight be where
players have been reporting that the
game still has numerous performance
issues the windows 7 users publish a
Warner Brothers interactive
entertainment noted that there is a hard
drive paging issue with some GPUs on
Windows 7 that may occur after extended
gameplay sessions their solution we
launched the game so basically have you
tried turning it off and on again
additionally we be advised Windows 10
users that having at least 12 gigabytes
of system ram allows the game to operate
without paging and provides a smoother
gameplay experience 12 gigabytes is
obviously a bit different from the
original 8 gigabyte suggestion that
would reportedly have been enough to run
the game on ultra I look at the Steam
discussion board also proves to be an
enlightened read with numerous threads
discussing ongoing issues with the game
beyond those highlighted by WB such as
crashing on launch framerate stuttering
issues with smoke rendering and
compatibility problems with DLC however
it's not all doom and gloom some players
have said that their gameplay experience
hasn't been as problematic and that the
game runs just fine but for the rest
given the complexity of PC
configurations and the sheer number of
them persisting issues may be due to
hardware or drive a compatibility Warner
Brothers has said that it is working
with its partners to address stability
issues on certain cards related to the
latest drivers they also added that they
are working to add SLI and crossfire
support due to these ongoing issues
Warner Brothers has announced an
unconditional refund program for people
who want their money back on the Arkham
Knights team page they wrote we are very
sorry that many of our customers
continue to be unhappy with the pc
version of batman arkham knight we
worked hard to get the game to live up
to the standard you deserve but
understand that many of you are still
experiencing issues so if you're unhappy
with how your copy runs until the end of
2015 Warner Brothers will offer a full
refund regardless
how long he plays a game for you can
also get your money back if you bought
the DLC pass but only if you return it
along with the full game but that's not
all sadly the refund process has hit
some roadblocks to according to an
update from vow for users still running
into play time-based refund rejections
we are looking into what is causing
those please wait to resubmit your
refund until we have this resolved thank
you but there is an option if you fancy
playing the waiting game Warners plan is
to continue to address the issues that
we can fix and talk to you about the
issues that we cannot fix later so did
you buy arkham knight on pc are you
gonna get your money back or wait it out
and see what happens let me know in the
comment box below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
on the Caped Crusader be sure to check
out our coverage on gamespot com and
I'll see you next time